it's an honor to have you here really is
thank you for doing it thank you for
having me conan
i appreciate it been a watching of your
show for years man
you're a genius very quick
i don't know about that but coming from
you that's uh i have a lot of respect so
thank you very much
i'm going to go right home to my kids
and tell them method man called me a
genius
absolutely um first of all let's talk
you are in
where are you right now i'm at home i'm
at home
staten island new york corn island okay
you know i like the idea of during a
quarantine being on an
island staten island sounds pretty safe
um yeah you know what when the whole
breakout happened i think we had the
lowest number of cases so staten island
did
you know we did pretty well during his
painting that's great and you're not
going are you going stir crazy during
quarantine or are you able to stay kind
of sane
now i like to think of myself as an
extroverted introvert more
more on the introverted side so this was
a like this was vacationing for me i'm
good
you're good you're good just you're just
good hanging around what do you do like
what does method man do when he's stuck
in the house and he has
nothing to do during quarantine what's
your go-to move
quarant um crossword puzzles yes
um that's me too i do a lot of those
keep you
to keep you you know what i mean and i
also do actual puzzles
white mountain plug plug plug white
mountain puzzles it's a
a website you go on and it has all these
different puzzles you could put together
uh retro 80s puzzles uh you know just
regular puzzles but they're they're fun
that's cool
that's great uh i just said that was
cool i'm not sure it's cool
i'm really not sure i have no idea the
fact that you're doing it makes it cool
so try it out try it out i think if i if
i think if i started telling people yeah
i'm doing a lot of puzzles during
quarantine
i'd take some [ __ ] for it but you're not
going to take any [ __ ] for it i doubt if
i do i
plus like a fight so you know
oh and i can okay all right